i [ __ ] with all judd aptos comedies i do
like them yeah but
that is what ruined comedy movies and
that is why there are no more i want to
hear this i'm in so far go on go on this
take because next time i bump into uh
judd at the seller i'm gonna have to
bring this up to him so go on
you made great movies jed you may you
made some of the best but you ruined
comedy movies because you made it about
identity and a coming-of-age tale and
comedy movies should be like seeing
someone grow into this kind of whatever
better person whatever kind of person
they're going to be [ __ ] that a comedy
movie is it's just like a sitcom it's yo
this a pet detective go
you know what i mean a guy with a crazy
golf swing go
it's a [ __ ] it should be simple four
guys go to vegas they forget everything
go
you build out
you don't build like let's go with the
story like let's go with this person and
grow with them and that's all his movies
are and they're funny you know what i
mean the last one what he did was like
40 virgin was exactly what it should
have been a 40-year-old version let's go
from here that's a great that's a great
premise and then it was like knocked up
like oh what happens if you get a person
knocked up but let's see the guy grow
with the girl and the girl grow with the
guy and it's like okay it's still funny
and then it kept going like train wreck
let's see or king of staten island or
you know what i'm saying like all these
movies now and that's why there's no
comedy movies now because that's all
they want they're like oh well this
works we want to see identity we want to
see someone become themselves or
whatever the [ __ ] and it's like no i
want to see
[ __ ] dude who can who go
like a really who like you know what i
mean like
that's a comedy movie and that's why
general in comedy books so you really
think it they he ruined them yeah
they're never
trying to copy him
yes
and you're like okay he can do it good
yes but other people can't do it good
but everybody's modeling off of him yes
it's like right now a comedy in the net
she did it the best well like with jon
stewart yeah it's like jon stewart was
amazing at it then other people tried to
replicate what jon stewart did without
the nuance they're just like i'm gonna
be left-wing about everything or i'm
gonna be right-wing about everything and
then the the comedy was no longer
surprising yes but john was actually out
there doing the work yeah i see what
you're saying ah well i don't think he
would disagree with that take to be
honest with you yeah so i i i take a
special skill to go on that that journey
that being said i do like the idea that
there's nothing redeeming about this
character
like i think that's kind of funny like
the pet detective thing is kind of funny
like you solve the you solve the problem
but you don't really change the guy
that's what it is i just want to grow
with that yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah i want to see the four guys
figure out what the [ __ ] they did in
vegas last night and and then still be
that way even happy gilmore grew but it
didn't matter that he grew he like
learned to control his temper
bro that's not growing
he's like learn how to butt
and it's literally about learning how to
put no but he don't [ __ ] people up
anymore and all that [ __ ] so he's
of the script just getting to its end
place
so that's why you'll never see another
comedy movie it's over just that never
seen nothing laura was the last great
comedy movie well oversee woo remember
we will never see another one in 20
years you know i think those are like oh
that's right something funny bro we're
going we're leaning more into identity
yeah
he's not funny that's not true the i am
sam two is coming out
jeez i also wonder if like tik tok and
other like external content has made
like funny movies less interesting yeah
why you know i mean like you're able to
get your fix as far as like laughter and
it's like if i'm gonna go to a movie i
want like big multi-million dollar
cinematics like theatrics i want cgi and
the whole deal and that's what you're
paying for and i think a lot of the
talent is going that way and they're
like i'll just make my own [ __ ] make a
ton of money and have complete control
over everything yeah so they're not as
cultivated in this i will say one funny
comedy surprising surprised me was girl
strip tiffany hat is so [ __ ] funny in
that movie that it carries the whole
thing every line bang bang bang but she
is the only part of it that's like that
the rest of the movie the girls are all
like growing to be better yeah yeah but
tiffany had this carries it over the top
she does so [ __ ] if you haven't seen it
you're i'm so impressed every line she
makes funny every [ __ ] line
yeah she made that movie no no question
you might be right because i'm looking
at this list top five or the top comedy
movies the last five years number one is
personal history of david copperfield
kill yourself
love simon
into the spider verse npr
this is screenrant.com
the funniest comedy films for the last
five years i can't i can't one of the
highest grossing let's look up highest
grossing that'll tell you something
because the people speak louder than the
critics
so far you're one for one okay
you guys changed the denzel argument in
the middle of the argument one one and
one one and one yeah one not one four
one yes yeah
guys thank you so much for watching that
flagrant two clip but before you go i
gotta tell you about blue chew you need
to deliver the woman you care about the
best dick that you can possibly give her
and the way you're going to do that is
with blue chew you don't want to be like
certain djs out here find out you've
been married to a girl for 10 years and
then she never came no you cannot do
that so get blue chew give her the best
dick you can possibly give her and the
way you do that is by going to
bluechew.com and entering the promo code
andrew and they will give you your first
order for free all you got to do is pay
five dollars shipping again that is
bluechew.com promo code andrew now go
watch another flagrant 2 clip